[Musique]
bonjour je viens div
bonjour alors nicolas sarkozy une des
figures de votre mouvement a été
condamnée hier par un tribunal
correctionnel
un an de prison ferme quelle est votre
réaction
d'abord je voudrais rappeler un principe
je suis républicain donc en tant que
républicain je respecte la séparation
des pouvoirs
ouais je ne juge pas les juges ouais
mais ça m'empêche pas de considérer
quelques points d'abord le rendu est
décision est faite par des hommes et des
femmes par des automates est par essence
un homme une femme peut aussi faire des
erreurs avec compris d'appréciation
ouais et je constate que dans la
décision qui a été rendue les deux cas
les fondements se font sur des écoutes
entre un client et son avocat c'est un
détournement de la procédure en réalité
puisque les écoutes est en train tout
cas la discussion les retraites
sensationnel
voilà sont sous le coup du secret
professionnel est en fait tout cela
s'est fondé sur ce secret professionnel
qui a été quelque part un peu utilisé
pour reconstituer la digestion et que
moi j'estime d'avoir un point j'anticipe
un peu votre question je t'ai j'estime
surtout un point je veux rappeler un des
fondamentaux de notre justice c'est la
présomption d'innocence mais nicolas
sarkozy a fait appel interjeté appel
hier comme d'ailleurs ses deux autres
prévenus d'autres personnes il
interjette appel à partir du moment où
on interjette appel et bien s'engage une
autre démarche ses démarches et qu'on
reprend le dossier à zéro et on repart
avec le dossier la première page on
nomme de nouveaux magistrats
à partir de là il est donc présumé
innocent d'accord néanmoins est ce que
vous estimez que c'est un jugement
politique gsm sans jugement sévère mal à
éviter c'est que on voit bien qu'il ya
une décision qui est très très dur qui
n'est pas anodine on n'a pas l'habitude
de voir ce type de décision de justice
c'est la première fois qu'un président
de la république sous la vème république
c'est de la prison ferme
c'est la première fois qu'il ya du ferme
c'est aussi la première fois que l'on
n'utilise qu'une fois des écoutes une
conversation
confidentiel entre un avocat et son
client
donc on peut en tout cas se poser
beaucoup de questions
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya un
appel de la part nicolas sarkozy et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya
encore beaucoup de travail à mener
davantage du sichon ce dossier le
parquet national financier qui a
instruit cette affaire et qui est créé
une créature assez moderne puisque ces
récents depuis 2002 13 est ce que vous
estimez que il a toute sa place ou au
contraire il doit être contestée dans
son fonctionnement
il a sa place mais il faut pas oublier
une chose c'est que nicolas sarkozy est
en tout cas sous le coup de cette
décision de justice sur une affaire qui
date de 2014
ouais il était plus présent un public le
pnf venait d'être créée il était aux
balbutiements son fonctionnement
aujourd'hui forcément l'expérience
faisant le pnf lorsqu'il est amené à
étudier des questions comme celle ci est
d'aider des procédures ddd dossier il va
beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup réactif
que je veux dire par là c'est que
aujourd'hui il ya une forme de routine
qui est mené et qui permet aux pnf
d'être efficace on parle d'un dossier
qui a maintenant plus de six ans sur
lequel il ya eu des interventions aux
diverses et variées on peut estimer que
l'appel qui est menée par nicolas
sarkozy est tout à fait justifiée je
pense que on aura une toute autre
procédure qui sera mené par la suite
alors les gars vont probablement
beaucoup plus efficace nicolas sarkozy
évidemment ça a été les mois dans votre
votre parti c'est une figure tutélaire
est ce que vous étiez de ceux qui
estimaient qu'ils pouvaient peut-être
joué un rôle important pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2012 de l'allemagne 22
bien entendu bien entendu et je pense
qu'il peut encore le faire une raison je
pense que vous étiez favorable par
exemple à ce qu'il soit candidat
je pense qu'il a dit mme lui-même dit
qu'ils ne serait plus candidat il a lui
même dit que c'est plus en politique
active il a pris sa retraite politique
dès la fin de la primaire de 2016
il l'a dit plusieurs fois il a répété
même ceux qui doutaient de sa parole il
a quand même rappelé plusieurs fois
qu'il n'était plus en plus inquiet par
contre il est dans l'ombre
ils conseillent ils donnent prodigue des
conseils
j'en ai vu quelquefois pas récemment ça
fait peut-être un plus d'un an que je
n'ai pas vu mais il a reçu des jeunes
parlementaires il reçoit des candidats
en tout cas ceux qui sont candidats à
droite
il a même conseillé certains prêts
présence d'un public donc c'est
quelqu'un qui joue un rôle dans la vie
politique et qui continuera à jouer un
rôle probablement pas en première ligne
un mec le jour a en tout cas dans
l'ombre et c'est ce qu'il aime faire ou
si oui qu'est ce qu'il veut faire en
fait nicolas sarkozy
on sait que évidemment cette décision ne
lui fait pas plaisir
ils veulent laver son honneur c'est ça
le but je pense que c'est son honneur
personnel on règle ça certainement et
puis c'est aussi vraiment s'assurer que
la justice dans notre pays fonctionne
pour tout le monde n'y a pas des gens
qui sont au dessus des lois a ni en
dessous des lois vous estimer
aujourd'hui que
les politiques sont de plus en plus
exposés justement à la machine
judiciaire bien évidemment on n'est pas
plus pour retourner à l'école en tout
cas on n'est pas protégé puisque le
citoyen lambda on est davantage exposé à
la justice du des réseaux sociaux ou
celle qui rappelle celle de l'arche
justice médiatique et bien sûr en fait
dès qu'il ya une un soupçon quoi que ce
soit qui rendue publique on est déjà
condamnée avant même d'avoir mené une
procédure et c'est ça qui est dramatique
de notre société
la justice est elle elle est faite pour
arbitrairement et enfin pardon tout cas
particulièrement graves on a justement
décidé d'une décision
est ce qu'une personne est acquitté une
laisse qu'une personne est condamnée
mais ça c'est la justice et le rôle de
la justice sur des faits avec une
défense avec une accusation
c'est pas les réseaux sociaux c'est pas
twitter c'est pas facebook qui doit
condamner dans telle personne alors
nicolas sarkozy qui probablement ne
pourra pas se présenter à cette élection
site anglais qui en avait eu envie vous
votre souhait c'est qu'elle quel type
d'abord de départage puisque le
président du sénat monsieur larcher a
dit qu'il fallait départager ce qu'avait
la la prétention de vouloir se prête à
présenter et quel est votre candidat
favori
bon moi je vais déjà répondre à votre
deuxième question c'est vrai qu'on a
évacué le sujet vous savez très bien que
je suis projet xavier bertrand ce que
james avait pas je voulais il faut le
vouloir maintenant de l'aisne député de
l'aisne puis surtout on se connaît
depuis plus 15 ans est donc aussi une
forme d'amitié évidemment jeux steam
qu'il correspond au candidat qui peut
porter une alternative réelle et macron
à la politique porté par emmanuel macro
qui répond plus largement à l'ensemble
des français
donc j'ai j'ai fait mon choix bien
évidemment je n'oublie pas non plus
qu'il a fait un choix celui de sortir de
la famille des républicains
il ya tout ce lien recréer entre les
républicains la famille politique à
laquelle j'appartiens depuis maintenant
près de vingt ans à laquelle j'ai dans
laquelle j'exerce des raids des
responsabilités et et puis lui qui n'est
plus dans ce parti dont il faut créer ce
lien il faut porter et il appartiendra
et c'est pas uniquement moi ce sera
l'ensemble du bureau politique et
républicains d'arriver à prendre une
décision claire sur le candidat que nous
soutiendrons ou la candidat que nous
soutiendrons demain maintenant il ya
plusieurs personnes qui sont
bertrand on prête la candidature
peut-être à valérie pécresse laurent
wauquiez n'est pas totalement sorti
sorti des écrans radar intérieur réalité
est bien sûr bruno retailleau
il a été dit dans lors d'un des derniers
d'un récent bureau politique que ce
serait finalement le candidat qui serait
mieux placé dans les sondages d'ici
l'été
cs 17 6% nicolas sarkozy avait même dit
qu'il fallait et à 18% pour pouvoir
l'emporter
je pense que voilà ce sera un prochain
point d'étape était on saura quel est le
mieux placé aujourd'hui les sondages
soient les régir la liberté autour de 16
17% les sondages peuvent évoluer dans un
sens comme dans l'autre
donc il faut à la fois rester très
humble par rapport à tout ça il faut
rester aussi très concentrée et
certainement pas tourné dans la guerre
des chefs comme on l'a vu dans ma
famille plastique est ce que les
régionales vont être décisives justement
de ce point de vue puisque quelques-uns
des noms vous avez prononcé se présenta
tus quasiment par bruno retailleau
est-ce que ça va être décisif par
exemple si la victoire est écrasante
pour xavier bertrand ça va être un bon
point pour lui oui toute victoire sera
un bon plan pour tous les candidats
quel que soit le résultat vous savez on
ne peut pas comparer un département
comme une région comme celle des hauts
de france avec une région comme celle de
l'auvergne rhône-alpes ou d'autres il ya
des réalités territoriales qui font que
ce ne sont pas les mêmes résultats on
peut pas interpréter la même manière
alors on le sent il ya quand même des
divergences ou des différences de
discours à l'intérieur de votre parti
entre ceux là qui estime par exemple que
la dette c'est doit être isolé où doit
être son remboursement doit être remis à
beaucoup plus tard et puis d'autres qui
disent banon la dette il c'est très
important il faut la rembourser ses
discours d'eric woerth
d'autres ont un discours beaucoup plus
social je dirais vous vous positionnez
où il ya deux types de tête déjà oui une
dette structurelle je parle de et il ya
la dette qu'ovide ce qu'on appelle la
dette qu vite et bien sûr sur la dette
coville aujourd'hui elle est détenue par
la bce bce qui rachète
dead qui les états européens je pense
réellement qu'il faut j'ai faut affirmer
que la dette sera remboursée un jour ou
l'autre si on n'est pas capable de dire
qu'on remboursera pas notre dette on
trouvera personne pour le côté de
l'argent oui
donc il faut le dire ouais néanmoins on
peut pas dire que sortir de la crise
on ira rembourser la dette immédiatement
parce que ça voudrait dire porter une
politique de rigueur une politique
drastique ou ont fermé toutes les vannes
et au recteur n'arrivera jamais à créer
les conditions d'une croissance
en fait il ya trois temps premier temps
c'était de soutenir l'économie au pic de
la crise sanitaire ray comme on l'a fait
en 2008
je crois que c'est ce qui est menée
aujourd'hui ensuite il y aura un
deuxième temps celui de soutenir
l'économie au moment de la sortie de la
crise sanitaire pour justement amorcer
la pompe amorcé la machine est quelque
part assurer une sortie en sifflet des
aides qui sont qui sont en place ça sera
nécessaire pour créer de la croissance
et puis un troisième temps qui sera
celui de la rampe du remboursement de la
dette
et cette dette vaut remboursement de la
dette doit être lisse et dans le temps
et non pas reporté aux calendes grecques
vallejo remporteront vous remboursera
dans un siècle n'a pas de sens mais
l'état les parce qu'on peut pas nous
quelque part dire à nos enfants et moi
j'ai des enfants qui ont 2 ans et 6 mois
leur dire c'est vous qui rembourserait
la dette qu'on est en train de faire non
c'est une responsabilité soit isolé
comme certains le prétendent
la dette qu'ovide oui mais quid doit-il
jouer et je pense bien sûr parce qu'il
en soit je te faut bien dissocier qui la
dette structurelle et leurs élèves dans
la dette d'accor est ce qu'on entre eux
vivent aujourd'hui d'accord alors le
président de la république conduit une
politique qui est la sienne et certains
estiment et notamment pas mal
d'électeurs qui viennent de chez
beaucoup d'électeurs de droite
finalement le candidat de la droite
c'est peut-être lui non qu'est-ce qu'on
distingue par exemple monsieur bertrand
de monsieur macron une
colonne latérale une colonne vertébrale
politique que la pâle président de la
république est par exemple un public qui
a fait du picking est-ce que c'est du
picking picorer ici ou là ouais est
présent depuis les petits corps des
idées surtout là pour plaire quelque
part à un électorat ou un autre histoire
celle d'un grec cible au début de son
mandat il a fait des réformes
économiques qui pourraient qui aurait pu
être conduite par la droite je ne le nie
pas mais on voit bien que son talon
d'achille c'est quand même la question
de la sécurité commence à l'ajustement
une politique de droite c'est la
politique économique une politique de
droite
une politique que droite au sens
populaire comme le portait en son temps
nicolas sarkozy avec les heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées etc
c'est de reconnaître que la valeur
travail est essentiel c'est de valoriser
le travail
oui j'ai pas le sentiment que le pays
est beaucoup changé on encore un des
pays qui taxe le plus c'est aussi une
petite droite une question de sécurité
et s'est réaffirmé l'autorité de l'état
regardez toutes les x qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans le quartier avec tous
ces jeunes ça date pas d'hier matin
c'est pas la crise covin les a créés
c'est parce qu'on a laissé quelque part
tous et tous ces territoires en zone de
non droit où n'apparaît affirmer
l'autorité de l'état
donc ça aussi ça fait partie du talon
d'achille du président de la république
emmanuel macron sur la question
économique
il y a des points certes de convergence
sur les visions
notre économie mais c'est pas suffisant
alors il ya une grande question
aujourd'hui de savoir s'il existe encore
un front républicain face au
rassemblement national qui prétend lui
aussi avoir changé de discours de ton et
en admettant que madame le pen soit au
deuxième tour est en phase de pouvoir
peut-être remporter cette élection est
ce que vous vous seriez de ceux qui
prônent un front républicain
on sait qu'à gauche il ya beaucoup
d'électeurs qui sont plutôt réticents à
cela je fais pas de la politique fiction
tu fais de la politique du concret et du
jour du réel et la politique du réel
pour moi c'est fait en sorte que marine
le pen ne soit pas au second tour de la
présidentielle politique de réel c'est
que la droite républicaine les
républicains et leur allié soit au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
donc clairement je ne projette pas pour
l'instant sur le second tour de bras au
ciel avec un scénario tel que le
souhaite emmanuel macron parce qu'en
fait c'est son seul salut de se faire
réélire face à marine le pen
moi je vous souhaite clairement qu on
ait un candidat face au président
sortant et je ferai tout pour y arriver
et sur le principe du front républicain
quels que soient les candidats mais le
principe du front républicain se posera
à ceux qui auront peut-être à choisir
entre le candidat porté par les
républicains face à marine le pen ou
voir même face à emmanuel macron à bien
nous sommes
avec julien dive ce matin dans l'est
dans l'euro dans les studios du figaro
et on continue avec les questions de
alban barthélémy bonjour alban bonjour
yves et bonjour julien dive
je commence avec la question de patrick
sur twitter pourquoi les républicains ne
sont ne se sentira engagé dans une autre
voie que celle imposée par la république
en marche pour gérer la crise sanitaire
comme ajoute il a pu le faire par
exemple le rassemblement national
d'abord l'un public a fait des
contre-propositions l'un public envoûté
contre la prorogation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au 1er juin
nous avions fait d'autres aussi
propositions alternatives
quant à la question c'est qu'est ce
qu'il entend en fait votre internaute
sur les alternatives c'est
isolé c'est donc sur sa question s'est
isolé les isoler les gens qui sont
attendus
le volet délire que vous n'avez pas eu
un discours très audible d'alternative à
ce qui a été conduit par le président de
la république et l'exécutif
on la porte est quand même bien après on
l'apporté bien après l'âge encore une
fois on a voté contre la progression
d'état d'urgence pendant la crise au
coeur de la crise notamment la première
vague
évidemment je crois que il y avait
unanimité pour soutenir l'économie et
voter le plan de relance je pense qu'il
aurait été complètement incohérent de ne
pas soutenir un plan de relance donc si
c'est ça soutenir la politique mais je
suis désolé mais je pense pas que même
le et rennes ne se soit ne soit engagée
dans cette voie là par contre on a fait
des propositions contre propositions et
on continue de le faire notamment
récemment l'a remis tout un tas de
propositions avec aurélien pradié sur la
question la précarité dans notre pays
parce qu'en fait la crise tanit et
renforce évidemment les inégalités
sociales avec une précarité qui sert dit
qu'on est de plus en plus d'indépendance
justement qui se retrouvent en situation
précaire et donc on a fait des
contre-propositions on les a rendues
publiques est ce que vous êtes favorable
par exemple la star à l'instauration
d'un revenu de solidarité active le rsa
pour les moins de 25 ans je vais vous
dire la question et des moins de 25 ans
aujourd'hui c'est pouvoir trouver un job
c'est décrocher un job bref moi je
souhaite qu'on puisse permettre à tous
ces jeunes éventuellement d'être
soutenus par l'état en contrepartie d'un
retour à la société
ça peut être soit par une mission porter
au sein d'une collectivité notamment la
question de la crise sanitaire
ça peut être aidé dans des démarches
administratives ça peut être accompagné
nos citoyens au quotidien mais tout
simplement il ya une valeur qu'on ne
peut pas oublier etc on doit surtout
érigés en valeurs cardinales de notre
famille politique c'est la valeur
travail donc aider avec le seul vraiment
une élan solidarité car et c'est clair
parts mais il faut une contrepartie
maintenant est-ce que la jauge c'est à
18 ans est ce que c'est
au delà de 18 ans c'est un vrai débat
qu'on a mais après ces inscrits et ça
doit se discuter mais avec les
contreparties en fasse autrement ça n'a
pas de sens d'accord alors autres
questions concrètes d'eric sur twitter
comment lutter contre la déconnexion des
députés en ces temps où les contacts
physiques doigts
réduits moi je crois que même si on est
réduit dans l'eau dans nos contacts on
arrive à s'organiser moi par exemple
j'arrive à faire la tournée hier j'étais
dans une commune dans ma circonscription
faisait la tournée des entreprises donc
je suis en phase avec la réalité puis
après on est pas on n'est pas des
députés parachuté comme ça issu sortie
d'une école de commerce ou une école de
sciences po je ne sais où et des gens
qui ont avons été élus pour la plupart
d'entre nous sur le terrain on est des
gens qui sont passés sommes passés par
des entreprises ou des associations ou
des mandats locaux moi j'étais maire
d'une commune
je crois que la prise avec le rôle la
réalité je les ai locaux vides ne l'a
pas interrompu alors marie sur
lefigaro.fr autre sujet vous vous
demande si vous estimez qu'il faut
interdire à l'écriture inclusive dans
les documents administratifs solidement
totalement contre l'écriture inclusive
je trouve que irrespect de notre langue
ni respect de notre reprographes donc
qu'on fasse d'abord qu'on met le paquet
pour faire en sorte que beaucoup de
gamins qui sortent de cm2 qui arrive en
6e soit bien écrire je pense que ça sera
déjà une bonne priorité est alors
question la dernière question celle de
manu sur lefigaro.fr et on revient aux
sanitaires
les étudiants sont en train de craquer
nous dit-il ne pourrait-on pas les
vacciner en priorité pour rouvrir au
plus vite les universités je crois que
c'est essentiel de pouvoir couvrir
rapidement nodyna cité je pense que
c'est essentiel de aussi de redonner à
notre jeunesse des des échappatoires
parce que c'est vrai qu'être cloîtré
dans un quinze ou vingt mètres carrés et
encore je parle pour la province parce
qu'à paris ou un avis encore moins moi
que ça c'est très difficile j'ai été moi
même étudiant et je sais ce que c'est
take est étudiant et bosser à côté
d'avoir des moments festifs tout cela
ils ont perdu donc il faut qu'on puisse
accompagner ces jeunes je note quand
même que certains pays ont mis le paquet
je pense à israël par exemple commune
pac et sur la vaccination la france est
très en retard et ça c'est quelque part
c'est au crédit du gouvernement il ya un
vrai vrai vrai défaut d'un campagne de
vaccination au débit du gouvernement oui
bon tout casser c'est fait leur échec
c'est leur échec merci julien dit merci
à vous merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions en question du des internautes
ce matin qui était relayé par alban
bartleby merci alban et puis évidemment
à demain si vous le voulez bien
[Musique]